I read a statistic a few years ago that
uh the average bad sales person will ask
seven questions in a meeting and the
average good salesperson will ask 32
questions
and um I want them to really understand
my business and me and my stresses and
then I really appreciate honesty you
know they say look we've got these four
products I'll be honest with you only
one of them really is good for you I'd
love to sell you all four but I don't
think you need them and that immediately
makes my trust go up and so I'm actually
become more open to all of the products
because I actually feel like they're
actually trying to help me
um and so I I think a salesperson who
cares about my situation and my stresses
rather than their numbers their targets
I don't care about your targets I'm not
buying to help you hit your target I I
think human beings are highly uh attune
social animals and we can we can tell
and the problem is is when we come in
for a transaction then we're going to
get treated like a transaction as well
if something goes wrong we're gonna get
yelled at because the our customer sees
us just as a it's a transactional
relationship there's no warmth or care
or anything because listening goes both
ways if you listen to me I'll listen to
you and we have to remember that the
people that we're attempting to sell to
you know they're human beings too it's
it's a it's a real opportunity to really
get to know them and it's a perfectly
legitimate question to say how are you
and as we said actually care about the
answer
no no no really how are you